- So what kind of shows do you watch now?
What are you into now?
- What you watching', Wanda?
- I've binged Bridgerton.
I watched Bridgerton.
(Kelly sighs)
Yeah.
- I just had to sigh.
- I know you did.
(Kelly laughing)
You was thinking about
that fine dude.
- I didn't even have words.
- Duke of Hastings
The dude.
- That's his name.
(group laughter)
I mean, not that I recall.
But yeah, it was nicely done.
Thank you, Shonda Rhimes.
So, what are you watching?
- Same thing.
I watch what my wife watch, so.
- [Kelly] Oh.
You know, she's the king of the TV,
when it's time to watch TV,
so I'm like, "hey, what's this?"
She turns me on, like Bridgerton,
she turn me onto that,
and when I start watching, I'm like,
"this ain't something
I'm gonna keep watching,
but, I find myself
glued to it.
- Yeah, next thing you know, you're like,
"wait, what's this?"
- [Wanda] Wait a minute.
What are they doing in that library?
Okay.
- And when no one's watching,
when I'm home by myself, and I watch
90 Day Fiance.
(group laughter)
- Wait, is that 'cause you're ashamed?
- Full of shame, full of shame.
I love that show.
- I know so many people that-
- Obviously, it's like a
huge, it's a popular show.
- Yeah.
- Two of my friends, right now,
every time I call them, they are watching
an episode of 90 Day Fiance.
I'm like, "do you do
anything else at your house?"
I don't know.